- Un silence qui er exprimer la,
pour réclamer plus d'actions
comme des hausses de salaires,
contre l'inflation galopante.
Les grèves de divers corps
au Royaume-Uni dans un bras
de fer entre des syndicats
et le gouvernement conservateur.
La première ministre, Liz
Struss, rs qualifié
ces grévistes d'ennemi de
la libre entreprise durantours e
du Congrès conservateur.issemen)
Un congrès mouvementé, marqué
par une fronde au sein de
son parti partagé sur
Lizz Truss a dû faire volte-face
en s'excusant au sujet de
les plus riches.
e la plus controversée
financé par la dette et
qui a affolé les mfolé les mfol,
fait plonger les conservateurs
dans les sondages,bonne pabonne.
Ce délégué reconnaît qu'il
en faveur de cette baisse.
"Parce que, dit-il, la fiscalité
l'économie."
Et là-dessus, Liz Truss jure
qu'elle va garder le cap.
st voulue à la fois
combative et optimiste
pour rallier ses tEn assurant ce
la résistance au changement,
aux perturbations,nt qu'en boute
tout le monde profitera
du résultat : la croissance,
sa priorité économique.
Mais ces critiques trouvent
qu'elle pas assez pour
des millions de Britanniques
À Birmingham, deuxième ville dun
vit dans la pauvreté, selon
Ce responsable du programme
que les réserves ont
fondu en deux semaines.
Il explique que le gel
des factures d'électricité
suffira pas pour bien des gens.
Il se demande si lteurs, réuniss
un congrès coûteux tout pr
savent vraiment ce que c'est
de vivre ici.
Pour cette spécialiste en
gie politique, Liz
Truss n'a pas la compétence,
l'intégrnécessaire pour être ene
avec l'électorat e
et pour montrer que le Royaume-
Uni est entre bonnes mains.Eller
conservatrice n'a pas vraime
eu de lune de miel depuis
son arrivée au pouvoir.
Que le parti espér
ça irait mieux après avoir
montré la porte à Boris Johnson.
telle dégringolade", dit-elle.Lt
impopulaire que si une élection
avait lieu aujourd'hui,
tion travailliste
l'emporterait haut la main,
selon les récents
Elle cheffirmerffirmerffirmerffr
son autorité au sein de son
parti. Elle pourrait avoirà resr
jusqu'aux prochaines élections
générales prévues dans deux ans,
surtout si les conservateurs,
en fin de congrès, finissent
par trou
miner leurs chances de
réélection.
Radio-Canada, Birmingham.